rené malleville on va revoir son premier
coup de gueule c'était contre les
parisiens
c'était lors de ta première avec nous le
24 mars regardez et quand je vois pas ce
qu'il y'a pas que les parisiens approuve
se dégrade de ville et il se bat dans
leur résidence secondaire est un acteur
mou et pourrait pas aller là bas et
c'est les mêmes qu'il était cassé les
couilles pour le samedi quand j'écris à
ceux de l'église les battre le compte de
manor et là mettant ça y est le c'est
l'idéal
on n'est pas d'accord vous êtes la capan
resté un peu le bonheur plutôt que de la
ville est bien là j'espère que cet été
n'aura plus de polémique avec tout ça
voilà voilà donc est rené malleville et
engels et la révélation ya plein de gens
sur twitter qui disent ces voix là
emmanuel fans de baba ça a été la grande
révélation de ce soir c'est baba rené
malleville malia qui nous dit il est
énorme
voilà nutella qui dit représentants du
sud grande gueule francs et drôle moi
perso objectif c'est vrai que rené a eu
un franc prend franc succès et regarder
rené malleville regardez le il s'est
habillé en tenue du moyen-âge qu'il est
magnifique regarder le bras des mots tu
es beau le corps tout lui va tout lui va
je sais pas alors je lance le stade tout
lui va d'ailleurs je le lance pour vous
donnez moi vos impressions hashtag to
leave à s'époumoner mais regardez moi
mais regardez-moi 6 et 7 mai mais cette
classe mais regardez-moi ces beautés mai
mais rené mais qu'est ce que c'est mais
toi mais il va t'amener sur les podiums
mais n'est pas allée pas demandé match
de foot
non mais tu dois défi nettoie mon frère
ça va c'est cyril da bonjour tout le
monde et je dois te dire que j'ai voulu
marquer la dernière mission mais génie
quand tu pour le cndd s'est repris d'un
peu original ou hortefeux
au dire c'est que moi je suis pas trop
le mec à face et là mon sens lui arrache
tout de suite je serais content content
que tu es invité par que je l'espère la
vision mais c'est une aventure unique
que j'ai vu que mes toi et avec tous les
potes ya autour
et que j'espère j'espère qu'on ne
reverra pas de sitôt
c'est pour y avoir participé
parce que je suis chaud que j'ai
participé quelque chose de rare et que
c'est pas demain la veille que tu auras
occasionne dans le faire ça je l'espère
a alors ma place au cas où j'ai pris les
armes au poing
pourquoi moi parce que nous au moyen-âge
en bois comme ça et je me lève un livre
de chevet la chaîne sun quoi roland bien
sûr la chanson de roland garros de
moyenâgeux j'adore ça et jeudi pour
l'émission de cyril que je te dis moi
voilà j'ai adoré que tu m'a appelé et
que tu que j'ai participé j'ai adoré que
tu me demandait de revenir en septembre
lui malheureusement dû prévenir que le
jeudi à ce que le résultat ya droit va
il ya bien sûr je sais mes amis emilie
se comprend puisque de ringo starr ils
sont très bons voilà et vont sonner je
suis très content and et si la dernière
aussi je le mets tu vois si elle peut
avec tristesse parce que benzema comme
commencé à connaître un peu tous les
visages des cas là que je connaissais
pas la télé mais je connaissais pas
personnellement et que j'ai apprécié
j'ai eu l'occasion d'apprécier
voilà je vais pas faire le jeu des
vivres mais voilà je voulais te dire
j'étais super content cyril qu est ce
que je suis content que tu m'as paient
pour les tous les jeudis on est vraiment
fier d'avoir participé
c'est comme ça y est et moi je qui sera
unique et 2 j'espère tu n'auras pas
besoin de le remettre à plat tout ça
veut dire qu'il y aura plus cher
peut-être pas bien sûr saad hariri et
rené je vais te dire les réactions sur
toi de nos téléspectateurs nos fans sont
incroyables
vraiment même les parisiens voilà tu
adores voilà ils sont très heureux que
tu rejoins de l'émission et moi je vais
te dire pourquoi je t'aime énormément
c'est je pense que tu es vraiment
quelqu'un qui a énormément de coeur et
j'aime voilà ta franchise
j'aime comment tuer cgem large m
j'aimerais j'aime ton personnage depuis
toujours tu le sais parce que je te suis
là depuis très longtemps ou mine de rien
et j'ai passé des extraits de toi
maintenant il ya six sept ans et que tu
fasse partie de ma bande maintenant ça
me fait très très plaisir et tous les
jeudis
je vais attendre en plus je peux te dire
je vais attendre de pied ferme
on va rigoler et en plus rené thème le
moyen-âge toit est battue va être ravie
parce que je tue sera classé à côtés
d'isabelle morini-bosc vie jamais rien
c'est bon c'est vrai c'est vrai elle
sera de retour lundi avec nous
d'ailleurs
en plateau isabelle c'est vrai qu'il
nous a manqué de la mer de l'autre tu me
mets valérie alors valérie est alors je
vais voir je vais voir ce que je peux
faire je vais voir ce que je veux faire
mais je te dirai très vite